three-time Grammy Award winners recorded
35 number-one hit singles over her
four-decade career thank you very much
she has sold more than 56 million albums
worldwide the country music icon returns
to host the ACM Awards for the 16th time
in April and only on CBS this morning
Reba joins us to reveal the nominees for
the 54th Academy of Country Music Awards
Reba good morning mornin so great to
have you here thanks see you again thank
you alright let's get to it
okay let's start first category duo of
the year who are the nominees the
brothers Osburn dan + Shay Florida
Georgia line Lokesh and Maddie and tape
we like all of those mixed up group of
the Year Lady Antebellum Lang Co Little
Big Town Midland and Old Dominion so
ladies ladies performed at the Kennedy
Center and Your Honor what to like
seeing your mentees on stage singing
your song oh I was just blown away but I
love their versions yeah is there life
out there they played it was beautiful
I was really thrilled to see them and
how was it being at Kennedy Center
honorees well overwhelming yeah you know
you're in that same group that Club yeah
and so just to see all the people's
names that came before you it was very
overwhelming but the best part is you
don't have to say anything you just have
to stand there and look that's always
wonderful ok good ok good we've got more
cards here let's go next we have male
artist of the year male or the honorees
Dierks Bentley Luke Combs Thomas red
Chris Stapleton and Keith Urban Oh Keith
Keith Urban keep up at night yes yes ok
female artist of the year okay
is Miranda Lambert Ashley McBride Maren
Morris Kacey Musgraves
and Carrie Underwood Wow category shadow
Brenda Lambert who just got married yeah
very how about that what you've won
seven times in this this category I
believe I have no idea
you have according to our research
absolutely uh artists like Kacey
Musgraves Miranda Lambert what do they
bring to to country music well as old as
I am as long I've been in the business
yeah great new songs a different outlook
on the way they do their music and the
mute and the music that they write and
choose to sing mm-hmm
so I think it's a breath of fresh air
yeah do you have one in particular that
you like I know you like all of them but
when it's time for you to listen to
somebody do you say I'm gonna listen to
fill in the blank right now do you have
somebody that you have a special place
for yeah Lee Ann Womack yeah she's a
great country singer and I love the
songs she selects and I just love to
listen to her oh that's good all right
one of the biggest honors is entertainer
of the year who are the nominees no do I
have that let's see oh here they are my
gosh Jason Aldean Luke Bryan Kenny
Chesney Chris Stapleton and Keith Urban
no women on that list no women what do
you think about what do you make of that
well that make me very happy yeah yeah
because we've got some very talented
women who are out there working their
butts off mm-hmm so I'm sure you'll have
something to say about it the night of
on the Effie my girlfriend's on this
yeah so this is your 16th time huh what
do you love about this show and hosting
the show it's fun everybody's in Vegas
nobody's at home so when we get to Vegas
after rehearsals after the show before
the show we can all gather down in the
lobby or someplace and get to visit I
say this all the time the country art is
in general and I know you can't you know
stereotype but I do think there are some
of the nicest people in terms of all the
musical genres I agree
why do you think that is I mean to a tee
when you meet them in person it's just a
very different vibe I get from country
music artists we're very blunt
we're very to the point and if anybody
gets a little uppity and a little on the
high horse what's a what do you think
you are yeah what's the deal I know you
perform in Las Vegas several times a
year and you told me something we met
last time about what music and
entertaining should be about and you
said you should leave your troubles
behind when you come in and that just
really struck me about the power of
music and what country music does how
does it help people it heals their heart
yes they can relate to it country music
is very relatable and when I sing a song
it has touched my heart or I wouldn't
have
get to sing and when I sing it I hope
that it touches your heart heals what
needs to be healed but on other the
songs that lifts you up and it gives you
some kind of feeling it also tells a
story rebo you've got new music coming
out when Oh April the fifth
yeah right around the time the ACMs what
a co-inky-dink and I've heard you say
that this music that you're doing really
speaks to your heart this time it speaks
to a person's heart how's your heart
doing these days my heart's doing very
well thank you for for asking why well
I've got a new man in my life Skeeter
Lass's oh and we're having a wonderful
time we've traveled the world last year
and planted on some more trips this year
having fun he'll be with me at the ACMs
also skier let suzi oh I like that name
yeah okay and tell us about this new
album what did you want to achieve with
it I wanted to go back to my roots I've
got real strong country songs and story
songs like you were talking earlier and
songs you can dance to Western Swing to
step in songs that I grew up with
because we played in dance halls rodeos
and you had to have songs that everybody
could dance to so that's what's on this
album and the first song that that's
where we played while ago was written
co-written by my niece autumn McEntire
and Hannah Baylock so that's the first
song I've gotten record from my knee so
as a songwriter in Nashville oh wow Reba
you told me something about what to have
in life about having a wishbone tell
that backbone in a funny funny in a
funny bone and I wrote that down just to
kind of go through life you got to have
a sense of humor funny bone the backbone
stand up to everything that goes good
and goes bad and a wishbone you got to
have goals mm-hmm and how have you but
you deal with setbacks in your life know
that everything happens for a reason and
timing is everything and no I'm with my
faith in God I know that it had happened
for a reason and so go on walk on that's
another one of the songs I have from my
past but have strong belief that it's
gonna get better
all things don't see I find I find Reba
so spiritual I think your music is
spiritual and I think that's why you
have such a good fan base but other
people just love you anyway but
music is spiritual music and we were
talking in the green or about the reach
of country music that it really isn't
just in this country it's really why
have a worldwide fight truth are you
surprised at some of the fans that you
meet outside of this country stories
that you've heard about people that
really admire the work that you do I
love to hear it
you know sometimes very surprised
especially when it's in countries you
didn't even think that country music was
even yeah like what did I say Romania
yeah you know it's just really funny
that people will say yeah you're I'm a
huge fan I said oh wow that's that's
wonderful but because of social media
nowadays I I can go on Facebook and and
Instagram and Twitter and see people
from all over the world yeah are you
already thinking about your opening
monologue for for the award show yeah
yeah okay share we got to keep it light
we got to keep it fun no politics oh
this is fun
this is entertainment we're in the
entertainment business and that's what
we're gonna be doing well the ACMs is
lucky to have you CBS News lucky to have
you doing this guess viewers are lucky
to have you back again and thank you for
being really looking forward to the rest
of your album I could only download one
song one song at a time when I was what
a week that's right Reba thank you so
much for being here my pleasure good
thanks for having me and she is
revealing more of the ACM nominees on
our CBS this morning Facebook page and
you can catch Reba tonight on The Late
Show with Stephen Colbert on to the 54th
Academy of Country Music Awards will air
Sunday April 7th and 8th 7:00 central
right here on CBS